there was a young woman who wrote for
the
dodge
college of film and media arts site and
mentioned how she had become a writer
and
that a lot of people had warned her
ahead of time that this is a cutthroat
business and she wanted to make it more
of a collaboration she says you're in
these writers rooms you have to make it
a collaboration
how does someone do that how does
someone thrive in a
competitive situation or maybe it's not
maybe there's some fallacy behind that
look you're going to encounter both if
you're fortunate enough to be well
whatever you become whether it's in the
entertainment industry or in the drapery
business you're going to meet nice
people you're going to meet not nice
people you're going to meet people who
are generous and collaborative and
you're going to meet people who will
throw you under the bus
and
i prefer
the nicer version of this when i was a
a showrunner uh the head writer on a
sitcom on sitcoms um i tried to create
that environment in the writer's room
that we're here to help each other not
to one-up each other or anything because
you're in that room for a long time and
week after week month after month i
think you get better creative work out
of people when you do that but not
everybody um
not everybody behaves that way there
there are some showrunners who are
notoriously not nice people there
i read about one in the newspaper i
won't name names here where the
showrunner said to another writer who
eventually became quite successful
herself was just screaming at her in the
hallway about how bad her script was to
which she said
do you want to go into your office or is
public humiliation part of what you're
going for here which he found funny and
then still berated her about her script
so i i don't work well personally in
that environment so you try and get
along with people but i i've also been
not been the boss in other rooms where
the show runner was tough to work for
and you have to learn how to
succeed in that environment too and how
to make that work for yourself or if you
get to a situation that's just
unbearable really hard to do when you're
getting your first job so you probably
wouldn't do it there but
sometimes you have to say
life's too short and i'm not going to
work in this environment and move away
so since we're all humans we all have
our good days bad days everybody has an
ego everybody has some type of agenda
whatever it is even if it's harmless
let's say someone's in an environment
and it's not horrible but there's some
issues how does someone survive and they
don't want to move on just just general
tips on surviving
a somewhat
you know adversarial
writers from sure well let's take the
writer's room example there i think it's
good to take a step back and say
holy cow i'm getting paid to write for a
living
i'm getting to do something that
very few people get an opportunity to do
i'm not a coal miner i'm not
cleaning out toxic waste from gas
stations i have one of the greatest jobs
in the world that i enjoy i get paid to
go be funny every day or to write
stories or whatever type of show you're
on
i i think that really helps to to give
that kind of perspective and to give
yourself that kind of perspective
and
also i think even difficult situations
our fodder for future storytelling there
that the person who's making your life
miserable
uh can come in handy when you need to
write that situation in a in a script i
give an example from not my life but my
brother-in-law's life he worked in the
radio business
still does um works at pandora now but
he was at a traditional radio station
was a general manager of several
stations in the bay area and his company
had gotten gobbled up by a larger media
conglomerate and the new uber boss
called all of the bay area
station managers into a meeting
and said to them
my goal is to make sure that by the time
christmas rolls around the competition's
children all have one less gift under
the tree
well i think that's just a nightmare i
mean i can't that's what gets this guy's
motor running is bringing unhappiness to
someone else's children but i'm sure
holding on to that as a piece of
dialogue someday when i want to write
that scene so i you know i think you
everything's material for you and you'll
take that as a plus and i think you can
also learn let's say you're in a
writer's room where the people you don't
get along with i think you learn how not
to behave so someday when you're a show
showrunner you remember
to not behave that way and it's really
important i um one of my early jobs
after cosby was on a show called the
facts of life
and a lovely woman named irma kalish was
the showrunner for much of the time i
was there and
she treated everybody with respect and
dignity and i learned a ton from her
about how to treat people on a show and
i'm happy to say that now uh her son is
after her sees me her grandson is one of
my students at uh judge college at
chapman university
so that and she's still alive she's in
her late 80s and still writing
so
the point is you can learn how to behave
or you can learn how not to behave
depending on what environment you're in